you
[Music]
so when we are starting out in in data
science within an organization within a
larger organization usually there's the
first one and the first one is doing all
of the things and just because a data
scientist can do all of the things
doesn't necessarily mean that a data
scientist should do all of the things
but it's fine it's fine because it's
where a lot of serendipity comes from
it's a lot of where innovation comes
from so there's nothing wrong with being
the first one with being the only one
with being the only one for years but a
that only works as long as the product
that your company is making money from
is not data scientific because otherwise
there really should be a whole team
doing this but it's also because as more
information is acquired as more analyses
are performed there is greater knowledge
that can be applied and so it makes
sense to start expanding on that team
and so what I'm going to talk about is
how do you do that the thing that
happens a lot when you have a single
person doing all the things is you start
having not just tech debt but you start
having foundational TechNet you start
having rickety duct-taped systems put
together that suddenly start having to
have resilience added tacked on top of
rather than thought through initially
and so one of the things that tends to
take place in an organization when you
reach this point is that you have to
take things offline in order to start
fresh or you have to refactor things
while they're burning - to steal the the
animated gift that JD had earlier with
the the weightlifter in the middle of
the fire and that's very true well you
don't want to do is reach that point
where you have to take your entire
system offline for god forbid days but
even hours so that you can fix all of
these duct-taping that has taken place
because the data scientist whose role
really should be analyzing information
communicating that information
iterating on that information and coming
up with novel solutions to problems what
they're doing is they're building
structures and a lot of the times data
science and data engineering become
synonymous when they really aren't there
different skill sets that a team needs
to have and so when do you grow if
you're the only data scientist in a team
when do you tell other people with with
hiring budgets that you need help and
how do you convince them there's three
things that are telltale signs the first
one is scope when there's too much to do
for one area of expertise or for one
pair of hands when you've reached a
level of maturity that it makes sense to
introduce additional expertise into the
team and also to increase speed and
here's the kicker the last one doesn't
happen every time you add people to an
organization you add complexity and when
you add complexity what you're actually
doing is you are improving your ability
to handle an expanded scope you are
improving your ability to mature and as
an organization and you are by
definition slowing down so unless you
are increasing the quality of your
underlying systems just by adding humans
you're actually not gonna solve your
problem so as you're thinking about
expanding a team and working together as
a team you have to realize that as hard
as it is to use sophisticated data
analytical tools to reach conclusions
getting humans to work together is at
the very least no easier so how do you
do it how do you get to a point where
you're not being penalized velocity wise
by having an expanded team you do three
things you add specialization you add
processing you add resilience so what do
I mean by that by adding specialization
I mean that you want to have different
people doing different things and doing
the things that spark joy so you want
data scientists science around data you
want data analysts building analytical
pipelines that are going to be
monitoring your systems you want data
engineers to do the data engineering and
to lay down the foundations that you're
going to be using
in your analysis you want to increase
the presence of operations talent which
is undervalued as far as I'm concerned
but incredibly important for for smart
organizations and you want to have
somebody who really truly understands
the product the financials what is the
pain point of the customer what is the
journey that that customer is going
through whoever that customer may be
whether that customer is an end user who
is actually walking into a store and
buying your product or whether that
customer is a tax payer and your product
is IRS like one would hope the other
thing that you can do is you add process
so have a this is something that I harp
on quite a bit have a documentation
party take a day move everybody to an
off-site location so that they don't get
distracted and provide pizza or pastries
or any other kind of healthier options
and and get together to explain what it
is that has been going on you know it's
a lot easier when you have everybody in
a room going like what was the context
of that what were we thinking about why
did that decision get made what were the
constraints that we were operating under
because one thing that is that that
happens quite a bit is there's a lot of
judgment that happens after the fact
where somebody will go up why didn't
they just do this or why the heck
wouldn't anybody have done this in way a
instead of way B and the reason usually
is very sensible because we are all very
smart nerds all different kinds of nerds
but we tend to be smart nerds and we
don't do things for stupid reasons so
document those reasons so that you know
how to modify those processes to fit the
purpose as that purpose evolves things
like authentication things like
governance provenance is also really
important so as your data traverses
through a system and gets manipulated
modified and used in in different ways
you want to add information metadata
about that data as it goes through so
that you use the correct piece of data
at the correct point in the pipe
for the the reasons that that you need
and also automation I mean I think JD
also said it earlier and and I can't
underscore it enough whenever humans
touch data they breed errors they
introduce confusion and automation is
great at catching those things
automation is not great at many things
but this is one of the things that you
really want to leverage it for and then
the third step is any resilience so have
a well thought through hiring process
this is literally one of the most
important things that you can do as both
a team member and a team manager is
making sure that the people that you are
hiring to work with you or that you are
convincing to work with you in your
volunteer endeavors you don't want
friends you want people who could be
friends with you but the the example
that I have is I have somebody that has
worked that I have worked with for years
now and upon meeting him I recoiled I
was like why who chose to hire this
person are they out of their mind
because AI wasn't mature enough to
understand the value of what I'm about
to say but also because I think that
person would never have hired me because
we have very different personalities but
what we have is a drive to to do our
jobs and to do it well all of the
different ways that we clash come from a
very good place and we are now able to
understand that any kind of conflict
that arises is not a conflict of
character but it's a conflict of
Understanding or a conflict of purse of
purpose and those are things that you
can iron out so as you are hiring in
your organization hire people that could
become friends but that you wouldn't
expect to become friends hire people who
are competent who are smart who are
ethical and who are interested in doing
what you're doing
onboarding is another really big thing
don't just know that you have problems
and then hire somebody and say good luck
here's a third of a wiki that is
aspirational and doesn't actually
reflect the systems that we have and
ask me questions because they won't know
what questions to ask so have a
methodical onboarding process that at
least gets somebody set up for if not
the first six months at least of the
first three months and that gives them
context to know what to ask culture is
really important so I have several
friends of mine who have been killing it
and so they're now managers and I've
been doing this management thing for
about five years now so I wouldn't call
myself an expert by any means but I I've
made a few mistakes that I can steer
them away from and one of the things
that that one person came to me and said
you know I don't like the culture that
my team is developing I don't like
what's happening and I asked him have
you tried to instill a culture or are
you just hoping that a nice culture
happens have you guys gone out to lunch
have you done any breaking of bread have
you talked about things that are not
work-related because the only way to
have a really constructive an additive
relationship work wise is to have trust
and the only way to have trust is to
have trust it doesn't magically happen
just because somebody signs a w-9 form
you have to work at it you have to be
intentional about it so set up
situations where you are building a team
and I'm not saying go do trust Falls if
you think those are ridiculous I don't
think they're ridiculous but you may
very well but there there is something
that matches the culture that you're
trying to build and build it don't
expect it to just magically take place
this is both about rules but as we've
learned politically over the last two
years in this country it's also about
norms things that aren't explicitly
written out but that are important to
you say those out loud and say and set
those as expectations and the last thing
is diversity and inclusion so don't just
have people who went to the same schools
that you did who came from the same
backgrounds that you did who asked the
same questions that you do who
understand the world that as you do who
are part of the same systems as you are
so for instance
in my role we we're a consumer hardware
software and data company and I'm here
in a personal capacity but for those of
you who don't know about me I run data
science at iRobot and one of the really
important things is what kind of
household do we want having our product
in it and do we have people developing
that product and thinking about that
product in the way in ways that reflects
those households because guess what the
people who are buying our products don't
all look like the people who think
computer science is fun because
otherwise they would all be working for
iRobot instead of buying iRobot products
and not just having that diversity of
experience of personality and a thought
but including them not having a one
person who thinks different who is now
responsible for reflecting all of the
the new ones that come from that
background so you want to make sure that
that person feels like they're part of
the organization and they're not just
there to represent that which the
organization is not so all this brings
me back to the point of what it means to
be clueless and we are all clueless I'm
gonna say that again we're all clueless
because there are more ways to think
about things than there are atoms in the
universe this I've not read anywhere but
I am a firm believer in it and I am only
an expert in like three of them and I am
incredibly Kulas about like 98 billion
three hundred and ninety seven million
thirty seven thousand four so how do we
know that we are ready to ask the right
questions well we're not and I think
having being that vulnerable and having
that humility to understand that there
are things that you're going to hire for
and there are things that you're not
going to hire for and be mindful that
those things are true not putting them
behind a dark wall and not thinking
about it and and hoping for the best but
being mindful that those things will
take place
and and learning from them this is a
chart by David Whittaker who and I think
a lot of you probably have seen this
before
it's about impostor syndrome and I don't
want to talk about impostor syndrome I
think this is a very valuable chart in
that sense but I want to co-op this and
take it in a different direction because
the blue is what we know and the yellow
is what we don't know and what this try
to say is we tend to assume that a
single person knows all of the yellow
when in fact you have lots of people who
know lots of yellows and I think the
point that I want to make is that's why
you want lots of people with lots of
intersecting overlapping but not
perfectly on top of each other yellow
circles this is the reason for diversity
it's so that if you have a lot of people
who have similar experiences backgrounds
and expertise there's gonna be a whole
host of yellows that you're never gonna
be aware that you should be looking at
and investigating and and investing in
which leads me to this point you should
not protect your teams from failure you
should prepare them for it because if
you're if you have a single data
scientist there's a lot of yellow that's
missing if you have two data scientists
there's still a lot of yellow that's
missing and I'll tell you what if you
have a hundred data scientist working
for you there's still a lot of yellow
that you're missing fewer and fewer
shades and sizes of yellow hopefully as
you improve on your processes but still
there's always going to be something
that is overlooked there's always going
to be something and you know what bits
flip I would not have believed unless it
had happened to me personally but things
go haywire when they shouldn't have gone
haywire for any other reason which
brings me to should you only hire
experts no no no new new have tons of
interns have tons of people who have
never done this before and I tend this
is their first foray into data science
because the luxury of ignorance is that
these folks who are extremely junior
don't know what they should know they
don't have
any of the assumptions that are
subliminal and are baked into the way
that we think because it's the way we've
always thought because the world moves
but our assumptions tend to be
sedimented and so as you bring in new
talent they know to question things that
you've forgotten to question again the
other thing that I would recommend if
nobody has read the book chaos monkey is
about the the resilience of systems and
Netflix and how there are systems that
are turned off on purpose just to make
sure that things can still function when
when part of the system goes down this
this is true for people maternity leave
paternity leave vacation your business
should continue to function if somebody
needs to go to a conference so you
should allow it
you should foster that kind of mentality
and you should use it as a test for the
resilience of your own organization so
I'll close with a couple of thoughts
where should this new team we live I
mean if you're a single data scientist
you're probably embedded and a part of
some organization but where should it
live I've been doing this for many many
years I'm not gonna tell you how many
years I have really great skincare but
it doesn't matter it really doesn't
matter and I'm happy to get into a
Twitter conversation about this with
somebody who disagrees with me because I
have worked in data science within the
finance organization financial
operations IT engineering R&D software
and if you're doing good work and you're
solving problems and you're having
people address these problems in new
innovative creative and competent ways
this is the least of your problems and
usually this is where everybody gets
hung up because when you're going from
one to many the importance is not the
nodes the importance is the edges the
importance is how people humans
communicate and an interact and that's
where a lot of the knowledge that you're
leveraging and your organization comes
from but the thing to remember is teams
don't scale and so once you reach a sort
of critical mass where you're not being
able to have that trust anymore because
those edges
are frayed and stretched it's time for a
new team and at that point you add
specialization and you add process and
you add resilience again I'll just if
you've seen me talk before eh you know
that I give the caveat about my voice
breaking every time but you've also seen
me talk about dynasties and intellectual
inbreeding and there's a reason why the
royal families of 15th century Europe
look the way that they did
there's also meritocracies and
survivorship bias and just because you
made it doesn't mean that that's the
only way to make it and lastly I don't
know if anybody here has heard about
super chickens but if you haven't I'll
come find me after because it's a really
cool story but in essence when you take
a whole bunch of chickens that are
amazing and what they do they kill each
other they don't make each other better
because excellence isn't binary
excellence varies and your job as you
build out teams is to foster an
environment where people can be a so
excellent but where they have the
psychological safety to not have to be
excellent and they'll surprise you and
so with that I know I'm the thing
between you and lunch so thank you very
much and if you have any questions
now we have time for a couple quick
questions for Angela if you have any we
still have the mics around
oh hi thanks for the presentation was
great thank you how big is your team and
how long did it take you to assemble it
to where it is today and so for
confidentiality reasons I can't disclose
too much about specifically how irobot
is organized and does its business but I
can talk in generalities and you're
smart enough that you can read in
between the lines so I think the teams
that I have managed and built that are
most successful tend to have about five
to ten data scientists of all walks you
know to senior and about three data
engineers to start is a really good size
and this is for you know a two to five
billion dollar market cap company for
context if you are currently the only
data scientist within an organization
and you are doing all of the things how
do you make that business case that you
need to bring in more people if you're
already you know getting beyond the
budget discussion of hiring more people
how do you make that case without just
like stopping doing one of the pieces
and saying you need someone else to do
it now the best way that I have found to
make that case is to highlight the
opportunity cost of not doing it if
you're only saying how much it'll cost
and how good it'll be that's one Avenue
but that only gets you half of the way
there I think the the important thing to
highlight is by not doing this this is
the revenue we're foregoing because that
number is gonna be much bigger
here are the insights that we are
failing to see here's where burnout is
taking us here is how we've gotten to a
point where the the scope of the
responsibility is so big that we're
doing the minimum viable solution and so
those systems are now resilient the the
likelihood that the risk adjusted value
of that decision if a catastrophic event
were to happen is taking the system's
down for X many weeks and that's the
cost of that so highlighting the cost of
not
expanding when it's evident that an
expansion is warranted to me has been a
more fruitful conversation and has led
to better results for Angela's
definition of better then then
highlighting what the cost would be for
an extra FTE I think we have one more
quick one here
how much butch back do you get on these
ideas and who would freak out the most
that's a really interesting question
there's two ways to answer that I am
privileged in that I get to choose to
work for people who agree with my
management philosophy so how much
pushback do I get I don't get pushback
because I filter employers out who would
have given me pushback so I'm very
transparent in the interviewing process
for myself to not get myself into that
situation not everybody has that
and there is substantial pushback
especially in organizations that look
homogeneous so not everybody can choose
not to work there but I have also found
that making the argument monetary
reduces the amount of friction so if you
say and I'm not saying this happens at
irobot because I filtered that out but
were I to say we are building robots for
software developers we're not building
robots for for home makers for people
who want to maintain a home and so we're
making decisions about how these robots
operate that don't match the pain points
of the people who would be paying us for
these robots again this is not true but
that's the kind of argument that can
help open up eyes for people who see it
monetarily as forgoing revenue thank you
you
[Music]